Andrew wants ribs yes that was easy
that's good some ribs oh wait tomorrow I
am missing today sorry American barbecue
arguably the best barbecue brisket pork
shoulder there's lots of cuts of meat
we're focusing on rib day on worth it
we're going to be trying three barbecue
rib spots at three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
the most worth it at its price worth it
we must caveat this with the fact that
we're doing this in Los Angeles well st.
Louis has some very good barbecue it
does not the south turns out there's a
lot of great barbecue in Long Beach and
if you don't know where Long Beach is
look on a map hey guys my name is Neil
strata also known as big nest of bigness
is barbecue and sandwich shop barbecue
is originally about taking a bad piece
of meat and making something wonderful
out of it we're doing better quality
meat and drink something amazing how
would you define your particular brand
of barbecue people assume that because
I'm from Texas I cook texas-style
barbecue there is some Texas influence
that I've learned from people all over
the country it's big mister stop I take
whole spareribs trim them and our rub
wanna which is called big mustards
perfect pork Road you got a secret rub
yes you wanna know what the secret is
salt and it goes in the smoker for about
three and a half four hours and what
kind of smoke are you putting in those
ribs what we cook on it's called a
pellet smoker and holds 240 pounds of
meat we're using pecan and sharing smoke
as an ingredient you know it's like
paprika or solved it should blend with
the other ingredients if temperature
goes down it'll shoot some these pellets
down into what's called a little fire
pot and there's a convection fan that
blows the smoke and the heat down across
the meat more traditional barbecue areas
do they shy away from this technology it
used to be considered cooking on the
dark side
no you have to cut logs and burn them
down in the coals I don't know about
y'all but I want to do all that work I
just wanna we have regular sauce and we
have the spicy sauce it'll make your
lips tingle but it won't blow your head
off that cool with you yeah I can do
spicy just later did bit or on top what
do you do is barbecue just eat it okay
got it my old friends
I like cream soda that was always my
favorite as a kid this room looks
slightly bigger so I'm gonna take it
Cheers Wow clean off the bone it's still
holding together
I love the rub has a very satisfying
crust and it's a little bit spicy when I
think barbecue
I think ribs drooling with sauce well
you have great smoke this is perfect as
it is I've always thought it was kind of
like nonsense the way that dogs chew on
bones like what are they doing like why
is that fun for you but this time of
life I'm like all right I kind of know
you mean guys rib break here with the
beans oh my god it's limey this is all
mine there's a lot of sugar in here
there's also a lot of pork in here this
is like a stew I'll just break out now
break bread barbecue is the best food
yes jinx double jinx you can't talk
anymore I get to eat everything I'm
going spicy sauce yeah Oh Cheers
you're gonna need him give me a moment
I'm gonna I got to eat this is lame just
censor even's face yes and I leave the
food for me oh that was the winner stop
watching the episode now big missed it
threw us a bone in the middle of
shooting you revealed that he had
planned a BB Kubek for us is it what he
said now I've seen you guys do your
thing before huh I want to jump in with
you okay rib facts they're generally
four types of ribs that you see in a
store your regular spare rib the st.
louis-cut real your baby backs and your
country-style ribs first thing
country-style ribs are not real they
actually come from the pork butt
boneless rib fact the pork butt is
actually not the pork butt is not from
the pig but it's actually from the
shoulder the pig is a convincing ham
it's magical but confusing let's just
react to that fact now so so do those my
name is Rory Herrmann I'm the Executive
Chef here at barrel and ashes I think
the most important thing that about
barbecue and you have to remember this
is it slow and low we start our fired
about three in the morning and we'll let
that burn till about 4:00 or 4:30 before
the ribs will even go in there you also
have your neighbours they must be asleep
at night somewhere around 4:00 in the
morning they start smelling barbecue
smoke today we're using a Duroc rib it's
a little bit darker of a meat has a
little bit more blood in it that way if
we cook it slow and low it contains a
lot of moisture and we season it very
simply with just kosher salt and
Tellicherry black pepper which we hand
grind we really want it to taste like
the great meat that it is and the smoke
that it is we use red oak specifically
because it's a little bit denser of a
wood we'll cook our ribs for about five
hours at 220 degrees after that cooking
process we use a process called crushing
it we'll wrap them and allow them to
rest for about an hour what that does is
allow the moisture to come back into the
rib the juices and flavor of within it
and then we have a mop sauce it's what
we actually brush the ribs with right
before we touch them on the grill which
consists of our Kansas City barbecue
sauce molasses some chili flakes a
little bit of mustard and red wine
vinegar just to touch on that grill and
get a little tacky
a little bite to it so how much is the
full rack of ribs here thirty-six
dollars half rack is 19 almost everybody
that wears the half rack turns around
and goes we're going to need another
half I might as well just order the
whole rack to begin with coming by your
drink it's a barrel aged bourbon drink
you really effed up by always being the
driver somebody's got a Dede cares
it's a critic recive shall I carve you a
rib please these are the first time
we've had ribs that are dressed up with
a little sauce Cheers
ooh is it much more really seasoned rib
and I like that a lot
so the slow cooking here is a lot longer
than big misters it definitely pays off
the meat is really loose it's a more
aggressive smoked flavor personally I
kind of like that one of our most famous
sides is the hoecake it's our version of
cornbread made to order take a hot
cast-iron pan and we pour that batter
into it into the wood oven do we hit it
with maple honey butter Maldon salt and
green onions a little cracked black
pepper comes sizzling at the table and
let me tell you you can't miss that with
other ones yeah it's kind of like blonde
yeah it has like a really nice soft
texture hey this is really good it's
really like a creme brulee cornbread oh
and the scallions on top in Chinese
cuisine there's a scallion pancake yes
this is like that but formed
interjection of it I think Adams to try
this right now on top rib tips put a
delicacy Oh God having a full body
experience with this report
this isn't picking pity comfort
okay the next location of barbecue is
gonna have to wait until another day
oh are you nice not nice ah again I'm
feeling a little uncomfortable with you
making noises closing your eyes I can't
be here now anymore it's how you know
it's good what do you think human ribs
taste like depends on the human what do
you think human anything maybe you
thought what do you think the longest
barbecue in terms of time was for a
single person barbecuing 96 hours the
answer is 8000 off of you were close he
cooked a thousand hotdogs 200 pieces of
corn 104 pieces of chicken 500 burgers
in 526 sausages how many ribs do humans
have in a rack of pork ribs you get
about 14 I believe do all mammals have
the same number of ribs I kind of love
it you know how a giraffe has the same
number of vertebrae as a human
they're nano that's a fact how's that
possible
they're just really big hi I'm Daniel
weinstock's my partner Mike Garrett
where are the owners of maple block miko
today we have a full rack of wood smoke
spareribs we've always had a passion
love for barbecue we hadn't influenced
it introduces some stuff in Texas and
we're just blown away by their process
and there are attention to detail we
believed if we could bring anything
close to that here to Los Angeles we
would be a great success and we get them
in we inspect them first we got an eye
for the general shape and size and
marbling trim those but rub simple few
ingredients with the right ratios
they'll smoke for about four hours with
peach wood and every barbecue culture
uses a wood that's the digitus to their
areas burns nice and clean it's nice and
sweet and unique to us I don't think
anybody else use peach wood is their
primary wood and so it's all commitment
to the flavors come out beautiful give
them the right amount of time to rest
your harvest Asian is here we've always
wanted this to be kind of a meat altar
as you walk in the door it's the first
thing you see it's got almost a sushi
bar effect is it hard putting a barbecue
restaurant the temptation every day we
do the quality check you know a constant
but we're dedicated meatheads for sure
we can help you out by the way it's
called Ernie's and help designators yeah
this is a handmade strawberry soda and a
classic here for all barbecue it's
Shiner Bock thank you very much - Barbra
me and two barbecue
I love pickles because they're the
perfect little snack it's a food and a
drink I like that the rib tip is so
attached that that a chewy morsel
dangling off the end cross swords
holy crap that isn't one of the nicest
smoke tastes it's so light you're at
summer camp and you're heading to the
nightly campfire but it's still pretty
far away but you catch the first whips
of it yeah
any lookin sausage here you go one some
more yes please ribs we've learned
narleen's neck gently sweet it's got
like this molasses sweetness to it
everything is tender and gentle and
feels like on a subtle being wooed and
it has some sides you're gonna wait for
me yeah this food gets me it knows what
I want to eat yeah because it's a good
food this food gets me at you I get you
yeah you know let's try a biscuit you
wanted to share half of one I've got
over I want to save a little biscuit for
Adam it's all about that biscuit smell
all right let's Cheers it ready I'm not
done buttering my biscuit
Oh oh my god you had a choice right now
Adam this is insane you know that's the
best biscuit I've ever had what no not
yet
how is that Steven stop doing that the
bird there's a bird above us and it
might take us oh okay it's gone we're
gonna go with just the ribs so based on
the ribs alone which barbecue spot was
the most worth it at his price barrel
and ashes probably had the biggest
flavor of the day and they were kind of
the perfect TV ad of a barbecue rib this
was the worst idea whirring popsicles
while doing a wrap up because you're
literally at the mercy of the melting
this is his idea by the way my favorite
and my were that winner was Niels from
big mrs. sammich shop they were
perfectly balanced and it was a really
powerful rub there it is perfect to me
the smoky flavor of maple block was
probably my favorite but my worth of
winner goes to baron ashes it's
reasonably priced perfect for a date
perfect for a family outing perfect to
not break your bank and those rib tips
Adam what is your winner nothing
compliments delicious meat on a bone
than delicious frozen dessert on a stick
that's why we're eating popsicles my
counts like a turd now way to bring it
all back to hell I'm finish mine here we
go oh brain freeze
I know your weakness Steven it's the
brain hole what oh oh yes